[Music]
hi I'm Hannah Dickinson and this is
cheers to you where I'm kicking off my
first round of the weekend by choosing
to all the people and stories that
encouraged me to drink cheers to you
Titanic - for your plans to set sail in
2022 promising an authentic Titanic
experience by that time all the icebergs
will be melted but people will be fat
enough to sink it Oh cheers to you David
Schwimmer look like for stealing beer
from a market the clerk didn't notice
because he was on a break cheers to you
Museum of the Bible for admitting five
of your most famed artifacts are fake
one of them being the Bible I'm a
Christian
cheers to you snapchat for helping
register 400,000 voters in the midterms
I can't wait for South Carolina to elect
Deez Nuts cheers to you John Mayer for
sleeping with 500 women 500 women and
zero allegations that's how you know she
refused Sarah Silverman for letting
Lewis CK masturbate in front of you I
cannot wait for that remake of a star is
born and cheers to you Fendi for putting
out a shawl that looks like a vagina
mine looks more like a knockoff in any
back room in Chinatown
well done Danna well done
another great episode of cheers to you
and you can check out our regular show
every damn day on the Comedy Central
YouTube page for this week we did
episodes about the best Jordan Peele
character roundup of Florida man news
and we even did for Halloween and ghost
pepper candy challenge this is the
reason why this video gets dislikes is
you walking on and making an ass of the
show Cheers
[Music]